ASSEMBLY BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER WE
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE CAN
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WHETHER YOU
ARE HERE IN PERSON WATCHING
VIRTUALLY OR ON THE PHONE LINES
I AM GRATEFUL YOU HAVE JOINED
US HERE AND I ESPECIALLY WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
PATIENT WITH OUR SCHEDULING
CHALLENGES. I WILL NOW GO OVER
SOME KEY ELEMENTS OF THE
STRUCTURE OF TODAY'S HEARING
WHILE WE ARE CURRENTLY OPEN TO
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC
VISITORS WE STILL REQUIRE
EVERYONE IN THE ROOM TO WEAR
MASKS FOR EACH BILL WE WILL OUT
TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES MAY
TESTIFY IN PERSON USE ARE
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE OR
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
WHICH IS LOCATED ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL. FOR THOSE
USING THE MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE THIS HEARING IS.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY BNKING COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
OR MONITOR SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
THE BILL. IF YOU WERE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A
PRIMARY WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OUR- FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE AND WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU
ARE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. THREE ZERO
EIGHT ONE AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE AND TRY TO HELP. AFTER WE
HEAR FROM THE PRIMARY WITNESSES
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS CAN ALSO
EXPRESS SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL IN PERSON. THROUGH
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION ON
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL
OR THROUGH THE MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE. PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL. I
ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. ONE LAST POINT THIS
YEAR PROTESTERS HAVE APPEARED
AT LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS
REMOVING THEIR MASKS YELLING
FROM THE AUDIENCE AND ISSUING
VEILED THREATS ABOUT POTENTIAL
GUN VIOLENCE. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF HEARING
AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC WITHIN
THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME WE WILL
NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE
WILL NOT ACCEPT DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR THAT
INCITES OR THREATENS VIOLENCE
EVEN VEILED THREATS WE APPLY
THESE RULES TO ALL PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROCEEDINGS.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE.
OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. SO I SEE THAT WE DO- WE
ARE ABSENT A QUORUM. SO ONE TWO
THREE FOUR YEP SO WE WILL
CONTINUE AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
GO DIRECTLY TO FILE ITEM ONE.
SB FIVE THIRTY ONE SENATOR
WHITE CAL SKI- OKAY FILE I'M
SORRY FILE ITEM SIX FILE ITEM
SIX SB FIVE THIRTY ONE SENATOR
WHITE CAL SKI THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US SENATE THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDS A SET OF AMENDMENTS
WHICH ARE DETAILED IN THE
ANALYSIS. HOWEVER BECAUSE OF
TIMING CONSIDERATIONS THOSE
AMENDMENTS WILL- NEED TO BE
TAKEN IN JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MOREOVER AFTER WE AGREED TO
THESE COMMENT- THESE AMENDMENTS
OPPONENTS RAISED ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL'S
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE. AS
PART OF YOUR PRESENCE
PRESENTATION PLEASE CONFIRM
THAT YOU AGREE TO THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND THAT YOU WILL MAKE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES AT A LATER
DATE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE.
THANK YOU SO VERY VERY MUCH MR
I DO CONFIRM WITH THE CHAIR OF
JUDICIARY'S PERMISSION I WILL
BE AMENDING THE BILL- IF IT'S
IF I'M SUCCESSFUL DAYS TO GO
THROUGH THAT COMMITTEE- AND IT
WILL ALSO AGREED TO THE
ADDITIONAL REQUESTS. FOR A SIX
MONTH IMPROPER IMPLEMENTATION
DELAY IN THIS BILL TO GIVE THE
PARTY SAID. ADEQUATE A TIME TO
GET THAT SET UP SO I AM
EXPECTING AND IT'S ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OUTLINED
POSITIONAL SIX MONTHS IS
OUTLINED ON PAGE SIX OF THE-
THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS. THANK
YOU SENATOR AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH PRESENTATION SOME. OF MY
PRESENTATION SINCE WE REMOVE
SECTION TO MY PRESENTATION WILL
FOCUS ON SECTION THREE OF THE
BILL A THAT REMAIN WILL
REMAINS- AFTER THE AMENDMENTS
AND AT ITS CORE SB FIVE THREE
ONE IS A BASIC RECORD KEEPING
TRANSPARENCY AND PROTECTION FOR
CONSUMERS- TO HAVE SOME DEBT
THAT THEY GO. THIS LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN PASSED THE
FAIR DEBT BUYING PRACTICES ACT
WHICH BROUGHT MUCH NEEDED
REFORM TO A LARGELY UNREGULATED
AND BROKEN SYSTEM OF BUYING
THAT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THERE
WERE REPORTED CASES OF
WIDESPREAD ACTIONS TO COLLECT
AGAINST THE WRONG PERSON
CHARGING THAT THAT THAT HAD
ALREADY BEEN PAID OFF AN EFFORT
TO COLLECT AN INCORRECT AMOUNT.
TO THE. THAT THAT ACT SECOND
TWENTY THIRD CHAIN HELP TO DRAW
THE ISSUE. BUYERS WHO HAD THEIR
DEBT SOLD LET ME EMPHASIZE
ADVERB SOLD TO THEM TO HAVE THE
OWNERSHIP THE DIGITAL OUT THICK
AND IT ALLOWED TO CONSUMERS TO
REQUEST THAT PROOF FROM THE
PERSON SICKENING COLLECTED DEBT
IT ALSO REQUIRED THE DISCLOSURE
OF BASIC INFORMATION SO THAT
THE CONSUMER KNEW HOW MUCH THAT
WAS SOLD THERE WERE ANY
INTEREST OR FEES AND WHAT WAS
THE DAY THE LAST PAYMENT. SO
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER. WE HAVE
REPORTS FROM LEGAL SERVICES THE
DEBT COLLECTORS ARE GOING OUT
OF THEIR WAY TO ASSERT THAT THE
DEBTS THAT THEY'RE COLLECTING
RIGHT NOW. ARE BEING ASSIGNED
TO THEM AND NOT BEING SOLD SO
BECAUSE THE DEBT IS NOT BEING
SOLD CONSUMERS RIGHTS AND ALL
THE PROTECTIONS THAT WE GAVE
THEM BACK IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
WITH THE FAIR DEBT BUYERS ARE
PRACTICE ACTS. ARE BEING
CIRCUMVENT SO THAT COLLECTORS
ARE TARGETING- IT'S THE SAME
OLD PROBLEMS THEY'RE TARGETING.
THE WRONG DEBTORS TO COLLECTING
AN INCORRECT AMOUNT AND THAT
THE CONSUMERS HAVE NO WAY TO
DETERMINE THE TRUTH OF THEIR
CLAIMS. SAID THE HIGHLIGHT
THIS. NEED TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
AND WHY WERE I'M BRINGING FOR
THIS MEASURE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE IS THAT THE CONSUMER.
THE BUREAU OF CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTIONS FOUND
THAT FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH IS ONE
PLUS WE HAVE. INFORMATION
COLLECTING DEBT NOT OWED WAS
THE NUMBER ONE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL ISSUE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE TOTAL THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED ELEVEN
CASES AND THAT ONLY INCLUDES
THE PEOPLE THAT REPORTED THE
CASES THAT THEY'RE COLLECTING
THE WRONG DATA. I'M NOT THAT
BOB WHITE CASKET. SO THE BILL
BEFORE YOU WOULD REQUIRE DEBT
COLLECTORS WHO HAVE DELINQUENT
GET ASSIGNED TO THEM TO HAVE
PROOF THAT THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO COLLECT ON THAT
DEBT. AND THE BILL WOULD ALSO
GIVE THE CONSUMER TO RIGHT TO
REQUEST THAT PROOF ALONG WITH
OTHER BASIC INFORMATION WITH
REGARD TO THAT THAT. THESE
RIGHTS ARE EX THE EXACT SAME
RIGHTS THAT WE GAVE CONSUMERS
THAT ARE FOUND IN THE FAIR DEBT
ARE. BUYING PRACTICES ACTS AND
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DOWNEY
KANELL KAISER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT. OF THE
BILL AND I WOULD URGE AND I
FELT. THANK YOU SENATOR AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. AND I DO WANT TO
REMIND WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES EACH. OUR FIRST AND
ONLY WITNESS AND SUPPORT WILL
BE TESTIFYING OVER THE PHONE
MODERATOR. PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH- DONNIE- KIND OF KAISER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION. IT'S KIND
OF CRAZY LIKE SHOULD BE OPEN TO
SIMPLY ON MUTE. YES GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS DANIELLE
CANDOR CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION WE ARE A GROUP OF
MORE THAN A DOZEN LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS FROM AROUND THE STATE
WORKING TO BUILD A STATE AND A
FUTURE. IN WHICH CONSUMER
RIGHTS AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE ARE
FULLY RECOGNIZED AND FIRMLY
ESTABLISHED AND TESTIFYING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
THREE ONE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. WHO ARE
DEALING WITH DEBT COLLECTION
ACTIVITY GOOD MEMBERS WORK
EXTENSIVELY WITH LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS WHO HAVE RECEIVED
COLLECTION LETTERS FROM OR WHO
ARE BEING SUED BY DEBT
COLLECTORS. ONE OF THE FIRST
QUESTIONS AQUINAS ASKED IS
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE DEBT
COLLECTOR. MOST IF NOT ALL OF
THE TIME THEY SAY NOW.
DEPENDING ON THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IN THE COLLECTION
LETTER OR THE LAWSUIT LEGAL AID
PROVIDERS ARE USUALLY ABLE TO
DETERMINE THE ORIGINAL CREDITOR
AND IDENTIFY THE ACCOUNT THAT
THE DEBT COLLECTORS COLLECT IN
A POND. BECAUSE SO MANY DEBTORS
GO UNREPRESENTED MANY ARE STUCK
NAVIGATING THE PROFITS ON THEIR
OWN AND MAY NEVER BE CONFIDENT
THAT THE COLLECTION COLLECTOR.
IT'S TRULY COLLECTING ON A DEBT
THAT THEY- TO REITERATE WHAT
THE SENATOR HAS JUST STATED SB
FIVE THREE ONE WILL REQUIRE THE
ORIGINAL CREDITOR TO PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION OF THE ENTITY
COLLECTING THE DEBT. IT WILL
ALLOW DEBTORS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS IS THAT
A DEBT COLLECTION AND IT WILL
ALLOW THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESOLVE THEIR DEBTS WITHOUT
EXCESSIVE. COSTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ADDED ON. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THAT IN MOST OF THE SOME. THE
COURT. HAVE BEEN A SIGN THE
DEBT IN THIS IS BECAUSE IN
MEDIC THAT. OR THE- WILL NOT
SELL THE DEBT BUT IT'S FINE THE
RIGHT TO CULTURE COLLECT TO
THIRD PARTY TECHNICAL. AGAIN
WHEN DEBTS CURRENT FIND IT
RATHER THAN SOLD THE PROTECTION
FROM THE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
THIRD THAT BUYING PRACTICES ACT
DO NOT APPLY. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT THE COLLECTORS
THAT ARE ASSIGNED THAT WOULD
HAVE TO PROVIDE BASIC
INFORMATION TO THE- TO THE
DOCTOR SUCH AS THE NATURE OF
THE UNDERLYING THAT. THE DATE
OF DEFAULT OR THE DATE OF THE
LAST PAYMENT IN THE NAME OF THE
ADDRESS OF THE ORIGINAL
CREDITOR. IN ADDITION SB FIVE
THREE ONE WILL PREVENT THE
DEFAULT JUDGMENT FROM BEING
ANSWERED IF THIS INFORMATION IS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE LOCK.
CALIFORNIA DEBTORS SHOULD NOT
END UP WITH DEFAULT JUDGMENT
FROM A DEBT COLLECTOR THAT
CANNOT. EVEN TELL THEM BUT THE-
THE ORIGINAL CREDITOR IS. WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND CLICK URGENT YOU'RE EITHER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND BEFORE
WE GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS I
WOULD LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL GRAYSON. HERE CHEN.
MARK CAN YEAH BURKE CERVANTES.
CHOI YEAH APRIL FIFTEEN GARCIA.
WHEN THE TRAINERS. DON'T. SO WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM AND WE WILL
NOW GO TO OUR NEXT WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AND I REMIND THE
WITNESS YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH OUR FIRST WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WILL BE TESTIFYING
OVER THE PHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH MELANIE'S
WAIVERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS. ASSOCIATION. STATE
THAT YOUR MIND SHOULD BE OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM MELANIE CUEVAS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE AS IT IS
IN THE CURRENT HOWEVER WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE AMENDMENT
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS WE
WILL BE REMOVING THE
OPPOSITION. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR IT BOB PAUL
AND DILIGENT WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF OUR MEMBERS AND
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR AND
HIS TEAM FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENT.
SPECIFICALLY AMENDING THE
DEFINITION OF DELINQUENT THAT
IT'S CLOSER IN LINE WITH
CURRENT INDUSTRY PRACTICES AS
WELL AS THE ELIMINATION
AFFECTION TO WHICH PROPOSED TO
REQUIRE CREDITORS TO SEND NOTED
THE BATTERY AND CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THEY EMPLOYED THE
ASSISTANCE OF A THIRD PARTY
DEBT COLLECTOR WHO SERVE A VERY
DIFFERENT FUNCTION UNDER THAT
FIRE. TO SERVICE A DELINQUENT
ACCOUNT WHICH COULD HAVE
IMPEDED ACCREDITORS ABILITY TO
BE MADE WHOLE AFTER LANDING
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE AUTHOR ADAM AND HIS
WILLINGNESS TO AGREE TO A SIX
MONTH DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
THAT WILL HELP OUR MEMBERS WHAT
THE TIME BANNED BANNED WITH
ISSUES AS THEY SIMULTANEOUSLY
WORKS YOU I'M COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH CHANGES. TO
REGULATION AT THE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL SO WHEN YOU
GREATER PUNISHMENT GOING TO
PRINT THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WILL BE REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION AGAIN THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THE MANY
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS THAT
HAVE COMMENCED OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS AND WE THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS. COMMITMENT TO
THE THOUGHTFUL APPROACH I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S. HEARING VIRTUALLY
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO.OR
SECOND WAY. SCOTT GOVERNOR FROM
THE CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL.
ASSOCIATE WHO WILL BE. IN
PERSON MISTER GOVERNOR YOU MAY
BE OUT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SCOTT GOVERNOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL SERVICES
ASSOCIATION. WE CAN CAR WITH
CBA WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. YOU YOUR STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
THAT'S PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
IT WE DO REMOVE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE WILL BE MOVING TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SEEING NONE.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION SEEING
AND HEARING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION AGAIN
SINGER HEARING NONE MODERATOR
OTHER ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO LIVE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. EIGHTEEN
SHOPPERS GOING TO GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AND THEN
PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE
AGAIN- TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CLOSE BURKE IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS- BASED UPON THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSE WE ARE NO
LONGEROPPOSED TO THIS BILL
ARE. WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL
I DO WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
ASSEMBLY BANKING COMMITTEE. AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. WE DO SUPPORT
PROVIDING CONSUMERS WITH.
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED IN
FOR US IT WAS AN ISSUE OF WORK
ABILITY. AND MAKING SURE THE
LANGUAGE UP WORK FOR. DEBT
COLLECTORS SINCE THE ONE OH
BILL APPLY TO DEBT BUYERS WHO
ARE VERY DEMANDING HE'S-
AFFILIATING. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR NINE AT LEAST ONE S.
YES WE DO HAVE ONE MORE- MISTER
CARE- AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW- SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE THREE
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU.
YES MY NAME IS DAVID REID I'M
WITH THE RECEIVABLES MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL- WITH
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARMY I
IS IN SUPPORT. OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MODERATOR
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE. TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE
THREE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. BUT I WON WITH
AN OPERATOR. HEADLINE TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS BROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BEFORE ME WILL BE MOVING TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION ON THE BILL
WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE ACCEPTED
AND THANKED THE OPPORTUNITY
STAFF AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. BACK IN.
AND THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB. FIVE THREE
ONE. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP THANK YOU MODERATOR
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE
ALL RIGHT I WOULD- LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR- SENATOR I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU IN THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR CONSTRUCTIVELY
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT ON THIS
BILL. AND JUST TO REMIND
EVERYONE THE AUTHOR IS
COMMITTING TO TAKE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AS
DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
WITH THAT- I DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. SO THE MOTION IS
BEFORE US DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAYSON I. CHEN WHERE CAN I.
BURKE CERVANTES. FIVE TWENTY
NINE FORTY. GABRIEL CRISTINA
GARCIA HI WHEN. PETRIE-NORRIS
HI STONE. WICKS. SEVEN VOTE
BILL HAS ABLE THE BILL HAS THE
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL OF
AND OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WOULD THANK YOU OUR MOTION AND
A SECOND FOR THE CONSENT
CONSENT IS FILE ITEM ONE SB TWO
THIRTY NINE FILE ITEM TWO SB
FOUR NINE SEVEN FILE ITEM THREE
SB TWO EIGHTEEN FILE ITEM FOR
S. B. TWO EIGHT EIGHT FILE ITEM
FIVE S. B. TWO SIXTY NINE FILE
ITEM SEVEN. A AB THREE SIXTY.
SB THREE SIXTY AND- THESE ARE
TO PASS TO ANY DEGREE. THE BEST
THANK YOU MOST EFFECTIVELY
RIGHT. THE MOTION. TO YOU WANT
ME TO GO BACK AND READ IT FILE
ITEM ONE AB- SB TWO THIRTY NINE
MOTIONS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM TWO SB
FOUR NINE SEVEN MOTIONS BUT DO
PASTOR HUMAN SERVICES FILE ITEM
THREE SB TWO EIGHTEEN MOTIONS
TO PASS TO JUDICIARY FILE ITEM
FOUR TO EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASSAGE OF JUDICIARY FILE ITEM
FIVE EIGHT SB TWO SIX NINE DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
FILE ITEM SEVEN. SB. THREE
SIXTY TWO- MOTION IS TO PASS.
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON
AYE. CHAN CAN'T HI CAN I BURKE.
BURKE I CERVANTES. TORONTO I
JOIN- CHOI I REAL GABE AYE
CHRISTINE GARCIA. INTEGRIS I
WHEN THANK WHEN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PASSED BETWEEN I STILL RIGHT
STONE HI TWIX. INSTEAD OF BOTH
CAN I OKAY CONSENT HAS TEN AND
WILL LEAVE OPEN FOR AT MEMBERS.
HE CHAPTER THE- YEAH. OKAY AND
CAN YOU BELIEVE. DISABILITIES
OKAY PERFECT. OKAY PERFECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BOB
TWENTY MINUTES IN TO SPEAK
HELLO. SO EVERMAN. TWENTY
ALLEGEDLY ROOM AGAIN OKAY. CHEN
WICKS I WOULD I POLITICAL
ELEVEN VOTES WILL KEEP THE OVER
OPEN AND I DO SICK AS FIVE TO
ONE LIKE US. IS THE THIRTY ONE
TO PAY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
CHEN. CHOI HER GET THAT ONE
THREE FIVE ACT. HE BOTH
CONTRITE WILL KEEP IT OFF THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR VERY YOUR-
THE. TWO THIS AND COMPASS- BUT-
ALL WE HAVE LEFT IS A CHEN
CHANNEL HAVE YOU KNOW HELLO
OKAY CAN DEFINITELY SAY PASSED
THE ON A. CREDIT. YES I HAVE TO
SAY PASS WITHOUT. TO SO. WHEN
WE TO HAVE SOME VOTES ON THESE
SHE PROBABLY SAY THAT MEASURE
PASSES AND WE IT OPEN FOR HALF
NUMBERS THAT WAY THEY CAN'T
CHANGE. THE WHAT HAPPENED HERE
BUT OKAY WHEN YOU SAY. SAVE US
BILL FORTY MIDDLE FOR THERE IS
SO THAT'S WHAT IS SO IT'S PAST
AND THE NEW OF VOTES BUT NOT
THE NUMBER OF NOT DON'T
COMPLETE THE YEAH YEAH DON'T
COMPLETE. THIS THIS IS A LOW
RISK BUT LIKE IN THE FUTURE.
THANK IT IS IF IT IS ME- HE
SAID HE COULD HURT ABOUT THE
CALLED. THERE BUT THIS IS A
MEDICAL. SIR IS THAT IF THEY
ACT OKAY. THIS IS THE OPERATE
YOUR ABOUT ME YOUR IS ON DISTAL
YOU KNOW. THEY WANT TO HOLD HER.
SB SO I HAVE THIS MONTH BUT I
HAVE NEEDED. TED. WE HEAR YOU.
SO THIS YEAR WHEN IT'S ON AND
REALLY DOESN'T USE THAT. CAN
YOU HEAR ME.
HI PAUL THIS CHEN
GOOD TO HAVE YOU IN COMMITTEE
AND WE WILL GO TO CONSENT
CALENDAR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CHEN. ALL RIGHT. HAS
TWELVE BOTH. OKAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PASSES OUT OF
COMMITTEE WITH TEN VOTES.
TWELVE TWELVE TWELVE MONTHS
THANK YOU. IDM SIX SB FIVE
THIRTY ONE FIFTY FIVE THIRTY
ONE DAY PASS TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY CHEN. CHEN I. I'M
SORRY I'M SO SORRY SORRY AND
NOT VOTING CHEN NOT VOTING.
DOES. NINE THE VOTE IS NINE.
BOTH IN EITHER NINE AYE VOTES
SO THIS BILL PASSES OUT OF
COMMITTEE TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. I EXTEND MY
GRATITUDE TO- THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE STAFF RULES COMMITTEE
STAFF AND LEGISLATIVE DAVIES
THE DATA IS THE DATA CENTER.
THE MODERATOR AND ALL WHO
ENSURED THAT THIS HEARING COULD
TAKE PLACE ASSEMBLY BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.